SCP-682 Vs SCP-1056.
Could this anomalous, body-warping kitchen
timer finally be the thing that shrinks SCP-682
down to size?
Let’s find out.
The objective of the test was to see how long
it would take SCP-682 to return to its normal
size after being resized by SCP-1056.
However, when the creature was meant to be
shrunk to a quarter of its size, it simply
disappeared.
It was later found causing chaos outside of
Site-19, having returned to its normal size.
When a Mobile Task Force was sent to apprehend
682, it released a wave that instead massively
shrunk the task force.
It continued to rampage elsewhere, manipulating
its size at will, until a combined group of
Mobile Task Forces were able to incapacitate
it.
Researchers concluded that it had not only
absorbed the anomalous effect of SCP-1056,
but enhanced it, leading to considerably more
powerful defensive and offensive body-resizing
capabilities.